♪♪
Justin:
The first director really gets
to put the stamp on the thing.
And then the other directors
have the difficult job of
essentially singing the same
song, but in different keys.
Justin:
Each one has been completely
unique.
We've had 3 woman directors on
this show
Logan:
and that has been so fun.
I haven't worked with so many
women in my life.
We're wrapping this season with
Clare Kilner who's just one of
the best directors.
She has a really specific
vision, but she lets you get
there in your own freedom.
We're not going to the adventure
place.
♪♪
We're finding Charlie and going
home.
♪♪
What about dad?
Melissa:
In the episode 1 there is this
beautiful moment between Margo and Allie.
Where he says to Margot "I
have this idea to build a boat."
A boat?
♪♪
Sure.
[SMIRK]
-Why not?
♪♪
Look, no no I I was thinking
about a barge.
Upside- plenty of space.
Downside- kinda ties you into
one place.
The end shot of season 1,
they're on that boat.
Melissa:
When the guy got exactly what he
planned to do.
Melissa:
He managed to get Margot on that
boat.
And now she's going nowhere but
with him.
Neil:
I think the single most
important take away from episode 7
is Allie's face in the final
shot.
Neil:
There's a kinda ferocity to his
joy.
-(Crying)
-Neil: There's also the first
real indication of a latent madness.
Justin:
I don't know what his end game
is.
But I alway get to a sense of
foreboding
cause I think how far up river
can you go
before it can go very dark.
(Crying)
-Dad?
-Stop.
It's incredible the power of
family.
Melissa:
When you see them no matter what
they get put through.
Melissa:
They will say to the kids,
it's not usually like this, but
we made it right?
That optimism brainwashes the
kids to thinking what they just
saw was really not so bad.
Allie:
Pretty good, right?
Mexican s'mores.
They're really good, dad.
Allie:
umm.
Neil:
They will never live a life
that's typical
for a north American middle
class white family.
Neil:
But are they defined by that
Americanness?
Neil:
Is that formative psychological
and cultural experience
Neil:
something which can be escaped.
There's no America.
There's just us.
We just don't throw that away.
♪♪
Neil:
Season 1 is a travel narrative.
But all travelers must at some
point reach their destination.
Neil:
The next journey is about the
destination.
Neil:
And be careful what you wish
for.
Neil:
There's a great line by Horace
which is,
"They change the sky but not
their souls who cross the sea".
Neil:
And if there is a theme to this
show, that's it.
What did I tell you?
It's perfect.
(Laughing)
♪♪